pascal il était visiblement très chaud
et il a aussi taclé isabelle voilà il
est revenu sur les relations qu'il avait
avec tpm paix et vous allez voir il
dézingue à tout va mais je comprends
plus que ce pascal je connais pas que
j'ai jamais vue de ma vie ce gars mais
s'il lui arrive à lui seul il a réuni au
bataillon
mes frères mais va enlever tu et à toi
je me casse pas les gars qu'est ce qu'il
a dit je vais venir à koh lanta bien sûr
avec ce qu'il veut sans ils n'arrêtent
pas de nous des fausses deuxièmement dit
ben je sais pas qui c'est mon frère elle
de nous voir un jour la vie des blogs
sur l'allée régler ça en ferait un nom
fu nam je te jure mais je suis maître
des orchidées les relations se sont
apaisées avec tpm p alors elle se sent
pas apaisées elles s'appelleront jamais
puisque monsieur vers des sma manquer de
respect m'insulter à ma saison dont qui
sont sans pitié cette chaîne qui est
touche pas ma poubelle ils s'en prennent
à tout le monde les gens d'actualité à
l'époque j'étais un peu l'actuel j'étais
dans l'actualité j'étais le en crau glee
mais le personnage de koh lanta il clash
ce qu'ils peuvent pour faire du buzz
pour moi c'est pas de la télé il faut
pas oublier que quand on est à la télé
hanouna il exilés rien quoi je pense que
le message est passé à lakki souhait
très clair il a le droit de dire ce
qu'ils pensent c'est parce que tu parles
conte en pyjama frère ont dû attendre
une heure je ne fais même pas que nice
ou bien visible avec son glorieux
c'est pascal le grand père
j'ai rien confié je ne le connais même
pas c'est pas koh lanta c'est que l'on
taille chaque fois que vous en donnerai
pas son aspect tard oui moi je lui ai
mis des petits tacles parfois mais il
est mérité
je vous raconte oui oui
abbas et vous c'est là qu'on a des
vidéos on va voir lors pourquoi il dit
ça commence à composer
il sait quand pascal et sur l'île pour
chercher le collier d'immunité est bon
il est un peu bébête pascal
ils cherchent ils cherchent en fait il a
la main posée sur le collier et il s'en
aperçoit qu après donc ça donne une
super séquence qui est jusqu'en même que
pascal n'est pas une lumière absolue
ça va franchement on a la confirmation
que c'est pas une pour que ces arguments
alors il a défoncé la pauvre sa belle
encore avant elle pas pourquoi la pac
est toujours là plus que jamais rien eu
sur lui quand même plutôt bien les
missions sais pas quelle nouvelle à mon
avis et je n'ai pas il ya un problème
avec vous t'es tu veux vous pêchu non
mais je vous regarde et vous êtes un
petit peu vengé pendant la projection
besoin on a dit isabelle voyer à elle et
la conférence de presse elle a passé ses
deux heures à dormir la bouche quand
ouvert à toute façon aller ils ont
toujours la bouche grande ouverte à la
télé comme ça ça change pas et quoi
qu'il en soit ce même pas que ça
s'appelle moi il n'existe pas et j'ai
rien à faire j'ai passé c'est plus
humain fans qu'on parle de moi là bas et
s'ils peuvent l'oublier ça m'arrange
on n'a pas dormi deux heures j'ai dormi
dix minutes les autres non mais
sincèrement plus non mais ça y est c'est
d'une beauté la france a toujours pas
démarré un ba oui c'est une cro 18 mois
j'avais dormi une heure ce pauvre
monsieur su parce que lui il avait dormi
beaucoup plus que ça donc part à
bruxelles
on était la même production à tf1 mois
que lui a faite il aime passer son temps
à se retourner à me photographier mais
une activité quand même pas très
intéressant où la topographie hilton
bedimo il te désire tout cas moi j'ai
jamais rien dit sur lui donc c'est
vraiment dur à la demande à la porte les
critiques c'est très bien les critiques
bien sûr c'est bien ça fait avancer
je trouve hargneux en fait un cours
gratuit il ya soraya notre coiffeuse qui
le dit c'est qui ce com
[Rires]
si quelqu'un d'aigri dans cette île est
en mal de notoriété il a fait polenta
pour se faire connaître donc il est
extrêmement amer demander qui peut il
saute sur l'occasion pour critiquer les
oraux tout cas je ne connaissais pas
c'est vrai des petites annonces sinon il
est mauvais il est mauvais en soi
deux heures sont à la fois